[Musique]
so what
je veux soutenir notre candidature aux
prochaines élections présidentielles
ça va les mater par l'ennemi sera
connaît plus ou moins c'est comme dire
très pote avec nico un petit trou de
magal elle m'a oublié depuis temps adam
la menace peut s'entretenir de veau puis
moi je suis certaine qu'on se connaît
tous les développeurs web karski way
qu'est-ce que tu et demi alors je suis
journaliste
tu es un bon moteur mais il faut que tu
te calmes avec les polémiques plutôt
crever le globalisme mort ce soir les
gens il écrit vraiment bien amener une
personne de ce genre dans lesquelles si
peut-être un poil risque jeu une
ordonnance c'est contre l' angoisse
j'ai besoin d'auteurs pour donner du
punch à l'escrimé chez bp dur cet été il
ya des choses plus importantes à faire
pour t'écrire de bons discours il faut
que je te connaissent mieux on est mon
préféré quand tu étais petit
le petit lapin de nos la chanson last
night in love par auxerre au moment de
fusionner je ne suis pas facilement gêné
par une mouche rien la position préférée
pour l'amour normale devant cristie que
non mais ces conditions la messe des
gâteaux
spacca que québec serait prêt à suivre
une ferme autour du monde et se
contenter de cinq minutes par jour d'un
tipi classe
on a bien failli rester m'a vraiment
failli mourir
ok pour l'évacuation oui merci à jean m
est ce que tu as des vêtements d'adultes
pour ce soir je serai enchanté de leur
look et fred pour ce gala je voulais pas
écrire pour des politiques car de merde
je voulais écrire pour toi
le public n'acceptera jamais une aussi
contre nature il n'y a aucune chance que
ça fonctionne on est en pretty woman me
ciel richard j'irai toi qui touche à
ambert
m
je veux vraiment calmer le jeu et éviter
tout risque d'une partielle ou totale
humiliation
c'est bon j'ai rien
[Musique]